what we have here is just a small sample
of the types of molecules that you will
see in a biological system at the top
left right over here you have an example
of an amino acid amino acids are the
building blocks of proteins and if we
were to take a look at what an amino
acid is made up of in this dark gray
color those are carbon atoms in the
white you see hydrogen atoms in the red
you see oxygen atoms and this blue right
over here that is a nitrogen atom and as
you can see a lot of these elements keep
showing up in these various molecules
especially carbon and hydrogen but also
you see a lot of oxygen and nitrogen and
as we're about to see phosphorus also
pops up a lot now this isn't a
comprehensive list you will also see
other elements but these tend to show up
fairly frequently for example this is an
exit this is a model of ATP adenosine
triphosphate as we study biology you'll
see that it's often viewed as the
currency of energy the molecular
currency of energy in biological systems
and once again we see a lot of carbons
in the dark gray we see the hydrogen's
in this off-white color or the light
gray I guess you could say you see your
oxygens again here the nitrogen is in
this light blue color and then you see
the phosphorous right over there in that
yellow color phosphorus this is a model
of a triglyceride often known as a fat
molecule fat molecules are used for
energy storage and once again you see
many carbons in the dark gray and then
you see these hydrogen's and then a few
oxygens this is a model of DNA a small
segment of DNA and this is a much more
complex molecule than the other ones
we've seen in fact this could extend far
beyond our screen in either direction
but once again you see these same
familiar elements you see the carbon and
the dark gray the hydrogen in that white
color you see the oxygens in
the red the nitrogens in the blue and
the phosphorus in the yellow so the big
takeaway here is that biological
molecules tend to be made up of the same
set of elemental building blocks and in
fact it isn't just at the elemental
level it can even be at the molecular
level for example in ATP you have what's
known as a nitrogenous base right over
here you have a five carbon sugar right
over here and you have three phosphate
groups or a tri phosphate group in DNA
you have something very similar the
nitrogenous bases are hard to see they
are kind of the rungs of the ladder here
you have your five carbon sugars also
hard to see and then you have these
phosphates as well in fact the backbone
of DNA is made up of these five carbon
sugars and these phosphates now why do
these elements keep showing up well
these are elements that you will see a
lot in earth for example nitrogen makes
up most of our atmosphere we have a lot
of water on the surface of our planet
which is made up of oxygen and hydrogen
carbon actually makes up a surprisingly
small percentage of our atmosphere about
0.04 percent of our atmosphere but
photosynthetic organisms like plants are
good at fixing carbon and storing energy
in carbon bonds and when we eat those
those become part of our bodies and just
to get an appreciation of what we are
made up of in terms of elements we can
look at this chart right over here where
we see that we are primarily made up of
oxygen percentage and body and that's
because we're primarily made up of water
and water is primarily oxygen it also
has hydrogen now second to oxygen is
carbon and then you see nitrogen
phosphorus we of course have a lot of
calcium calcium of course used in bones
but it's also used for things like
muscle contractions and I could keep on
going down this list and you will see
these other elements in your study of
biology but the big picture is is that
even though biological systems can get
fairly complex they're made up of
similar building blocks and these
elemental building blocks come from the
environment in which these
biological systems exist and evolved